hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to shotgun farmers now
imagine yourself an old country bumpkin
out in the field looking after your
crops when all the sudden other farmers
want to come in and steal what once was
yours so the only weapon you got a hand
is new berry crops you were trying to
attend to I'm going to drop this stupid
action and I'm gonna play this with some
bees be pulled quickly I don't know what
we're playing but I hope it's going to
be good so this is a game it's a
multiplayer shooter where the only thing
that you can do is shoot with your very
crush point
sorry I missed fired miss the perfectly
bat melee slam what a laugh and you know
what I'm gonna go back to the lobby here
looks fine let's find something here
fight me I'm gonna I'm gonna fight this
guy place it's got because I know what
I'll do when the plants grow faster near
water
hello eliminate the Golden Hill farmer
Ranger things hi you have something in
your head
oh why hello delightful cows oh no
exploding pigeon you [ __ ] with me bro
where are you gonna get it are you gonna
get it you gonna get it you're gonna get
it you don't get oh [ __ ] hi hi buddy
who's gonna get got who wants to get God
anybody want a piece of mind yeah oh I
thought I had you damn at Oh everyone
else is getting kills but me use a bunch
of [ __ ] and good thing we got an afk
over there that's really useful I'm
super happy about that Hey Marvis Wow
oh come on why is everyone else able to
kill in I'm not able to kill them a
bunch of [ __ ] more summative right
outside my door yeah get killed it
killed it killed bruh pulled doop-doop
[Music]
t.o.p pistol dude the little it did then
rootin tootin Hootin ah I'm peppering
you from a way long way down a room boy
I'm out of whoa out of ammo let me just
grab some of this so I can shoot these
eight holes into the wood o get rekt oh
[Laughter]
ha ha ha don't know if I can reload
I think I'm gonna be oh nope
yep I'm out I'm gonna whack you with a
shovel whoo you can't be quack no more
good whack oh I didn't whack hard enough
I didn't whack hard enough where are you
guys in a mission man I got whoa okay
that doesn't make any sense about the
lethality of these slugs because they
are they are real powerful apparently
[Music]
hey hey what I'm not getting insist on
that I caught some of you but not enough
of you see why is that that seems like
extremely thala tea and yet Oh
get rekt revenge records don't matter if
they killed me matters if I killed em
right that's what matters
I can even shut Cory what short cord oh
wow that guy went on a spree that guy's
way better than I am
apparently that's okay I've got
overconfidence on my side I don't think
they do
oh I need something else please
something more substantial please
aw excuse my pathetic performance
yeehee whoa hahaha Oh give me that
yeah oh you want to go bro you want to
go you want to go oh god don't go don't
go ha ha revenge beatdown that's a
winning for me
apparently rootin tootin Hootin trying
to tell me what to do I know what I'm
doing
what what what what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that what a bunch of [ __ ] aah got
you aah I got you okay that's not good
but I'm gonna grab one of these bad boys
here who almost dead oh now give me some
systems this oh uh uh oh I just got a
snake arrogance I just get us from the
frickin slipper Gus ah got you all that
sniper Gus ain't gonna be there no more
ain't it oh it is one shot though
there's all I need this snuper Gus ain't
gonna be not ILI's utilize all creek a
snuper Gus didn't work not the way I
intended my sniper goes to work ah what
you got there Karen Jesus that wasn't
just a kick up the carrot launch it is
seems hey we did it
whoa all right take some of that I
didn't do too good but that's all right
I got a new hat and that's all that
matters
that's what I wanted anyway that was
really cool anyway I've actually never
played this game before I saw it and I
just liked the concept of it there way
to practice against plots or anything or
is it just practice here oh [ __ ]
okay that's pots okay I'll eliminate the
red farmers I didn't know that we would
be going right into this can I get a
sniper Gus first god damn hose is
completely different ooh
rustic okay I just wanted to play around
against a full group
well it seems almost comically easy oh
our you miss me well it seems a lot
easier than playing against real real
players
that's okay I'll take the easy killing
stop laughing oh that's alright
wonk it one pitch high I'm almost dead
oh oh I'm milking it miss me oh now I
need me I'm more nerd okay utterly
ridiculous I know right okay I'm on a
roll okay against box just what I was
gonna say against silly stupid little
but but you know would you take what you
can get I want to find another carrot
launcher I want to see how that works
against it the unending hordes but I
guess I'll take a sniper gift shut up
there's Munson point point weird huh
[Music]
Oh Oh the buds got better or I got worse
I don't know which one is good I gotta
find the carrot bomb more sniffles yeah
I'm gonna get a vantage point here what
you think you're doing
point Elk Point there we go what are you
doing standing out in the open like that
oh no we're not gonna kill you well I
can't kill nobody parently yeah / - okay
you're dead now well I guess that's it
for that then and someone please lead me
to a goddamn carrot bomb huh hello yes
please win le that went awry I owe
only one I want a bunch of bull
it was gonna be run way faster with the
shovel that's why everyone was doing the
shovel uh this makes a lot more sense
oh that is way faster
Pinsky that was it [ __ ] Sookie stop
moving your frickin douches let me gooo
ski-doo ski gods just a bad Jew skirt
final through these until I can get
another freakin carrot bear I'm Oh tiny
carrot I'm gonna be great someday I'll
take you now though all right you're
ready for a whole face full this [ __ ]
was going on what you guys got going on
what's going on hey stop it Hank stop
what have you lived it aha
cucumber cucumber I want a cucumber
there's a cure that's the thing like if
I shoot and miss with the carrot that
means someone else is gonna get it right
no works I think anyway Chuck
and come are you drunk yuppie you'll be
oh well hey warmest I'm not as good as I
was hoping I would be I'm losing it for
our team here I'm really really sucking
it up here all right
tonight para guess what nope yep there
we go going to the top of the tower a
little boy hello I can see the whole
world from opium point you can see the
whole world from down there now that
your eyes are on the other side of your
face boy oh come on we all owe nones
alive apparently all right then I'll go
get a frickin carrot BAM
this is a fully harvested cure it'd be
him no not quite
ooh does anybody want to get keratin can
I rocket jump the [ __ ] out of somebody
please tell me I can please please tell
me it is so hey why don't you group
together let's like that that'd be great
thank you for that
well that really made me feel good oh
yes this is gonna make me feel even
better
danke danke so don't kill to thinking so
triple kill no it can't be stole it is
too violent for me how can anybody
survive oh look at thinking carrot gonna
turn into big Splosion get ready for the
big moment missed it went right through
you al tails
look I killed many didn't mean to
suddenly happen it is face deep in face
Oh No you get one pitch or no excuse
excuse me excuse me
a brisk use a little celery I'm so sorry
about this one watch and learn
carrot hello death thank you
there's lots of carrots round here
couple story just on the rampage can't
help it - good four pounds
you get perfect bands so what is suppose
it's the P gun
okay well that's nice I think so kind of
a point point point like did anybody oh
I've got the one pal back I got one back
in return well I sure got confident when
I started playing against stupid box
hey I wanna get stupid BOTS I feel
validated in my life that was pretty fun
that was really fun I got it missed this
game is really fun definite thing about
it right it's good right ooh
Kanaka Oh trucker crap yeah oh can I get
Pinker you're gonna come to you're gonna
get a most off [ __ ] yeah get make me
fall [ __ ] oh good
give me that face skin color good it is
uh eye color
we're turd brown nose color quick and
got the tumbler nose going on here make
it super red for some reason voice
is his ah man more people need to play
this it's so fun
oh why don't more people play this it's
so fun
ah that's cool I hope you guys play more
I'm actually all out of time for this
episode here but this is a really fun
game I mean it costs like I think it's
like 10 bucks I have nothing to do with
the game so I've no stake in it but it's
really fun I gotta admit it's really fun
and they're like the bots are da moon
them whatever but like it's charming
it's well-made I like it the concept is
good I wish it was more dynamic between
shooting and getting guns but still
that's really cool so anyway that's all
the time I got so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think down in the comments below if you
playing it for yourself you might just
see me on the server so thanks again and
as always I will see you in
[Music]